Life imitates art and art imitates life,
but sometimes, fiction and reality come
a little too close for comfort. From
specific causes of death to predictions
of national tragedies, no one intended
these episodes of TV to be so haunting.
Since news broke on October 28, 2023, of Matthew
Perry's death, "Friends" fans have been reeling
over the loss of the man behind the sarcastic and
loveable Chandler Bing. For many, their comfort
show now has a dark cloud over it, especially
since two episodes eerily foreshadow his death.
In Season 9, Episode 8, "The One with Rachel's
Other Sister," Chandler suggests to Monica that
they use their expensive wedding plates
for Thanksgiving dinner. She's hesitant,
but obliges. Though the plates survive the
tense meal, it's Chandler who accidentally
knocks over the entire box of them, shattering
the dishes on the floor. He tells his friends,
"Well, what do you know? I guess
I'll be the one who dies first."
While intended as a gag, this line
takes on a whole new meaning now
as Perry is indeed the first of the
core six cast members to pass away.
Similarly, in Season 7, Episode
5, "The One with the Engagement
Picture," Chandler struggles to
smile properly for a photo to
announce his and Monica's engagement in
the newspaper. A frustrated Monica says,
"This picture is supposed to say,
'Geller and Bing to be married,' not,
'Local woman saves drowning moron!'"
Authorities initially believed Perry
to have died in a drowning incident,
though the exact cause of his death is still
being investigated as of the making of this video.
Given the circumstances, some fans are calling
for Monica's line to be cut from the episode.
One of the most heartbreaking "Modern
Family" storylines comes in Season 11,
Episode 11 "Legacy," when Ty Burrell's Phil Dunphy
grows concerned about his aging father Frank,
when he's discovered seemingly lost in
the grocery store. Frank, played by the
legendary Fred Willard, assures his son that he's
fine, and they spend an enjoyable day together.
Little does Phil know, it's their final day
together, and Frank passes away soon after.
The episode aired on January 15,
2020, and, exactly four months later,
Willard died at the age of 86. Just as
Phil and Frank spent the latter's last
moments reflecting on their relationship
and ending the day on a hopeful note,
Burrell and Willard did the same during their
last moments together on the "Modern Family" set.
Frank knew his time was coming to an end,
and Burrell believes Willard did too,
even while filming the death of
his "Modern Family" character.
Burrell said in a tribute to Willard
published in Entertainment Weekly,
"The reason that moment was so poignant
was that he knew his time was limited,
and the only real way for him to say goodbye was
to say, 'I'll see you on the next one.' That's
the way he always thought. He said it with a
wink, and he knew that that wasn't the case."
In 2015, the Season 1 finale of "Mr. Robot" was
postponed from airing on USA Network because one
scene is darkly similar to a devastating killing
in Roanoke, Virginia, the week before its original
release date. The episode shows James Plouffe,
executive vice president of technology for E Corp,
shooting himself on national television due
to the irreversibility of the Five/Nine Hack.
Just days before the "Mr. Robot" finale was
due to air, former WDBJ reporter Vester Lee
Flanagan II shot and killed two of his past
colleagues — reporter Alison Parker, 24,
and cameraman Adam Ward, 27, — while
they were live on the air covering
the 50th anniversary of Smith Mountain
Lake. Flanagan, who also shot himself,
was previously fired from WDBJ for
problematic behavior. He had sued the
station for discriminating against him, but his
lawsuit was ruled as baseless, ABC News reported.
Ultimately, the "Mr. Robot" finale was postponed
out of sympathy and respect for the victims'
loved ones, since the events that unfold in it are
disturbingly reminiscent of the real-life events.
Throughout the run of "Scrubs," the hospital's
unnamed janitor makes the life of the lead,
J.D., as difficult as possible. He's
always pulling pranks, annoying him,
and bending the truth. However, one comment
made by Janitor became eerily factual,
four years after it was uttered on "Scrubs."
In Season 6, Episode 7, Iraq veteran
Brian Dancer comes to Sacred Heart
suffering memory loss due to a head injury.
As a result, the war becomes a major topic
of conversation among the staff. At the
end of the episode, Janitor tells J.D.,
"In my opinion, we should be
looking for bin Laden in Pakistan."
In May 2011, four years after the episode aired
and nearly a decade after al-Qaeda leader Osama
bin Laden orchestrated the terrorist attack
on New York City's World Trade Center towers,
U.S. Navy SEALs located him in Pakistan,
where he was swiftly executed. So maybe not
everything that came out of Janitor's
mouth was a downright lie after all.
The short-lived "X-Files" spinoff "The Lone
Gunmen" isn't all that well remembered,
including its seeming prediction of the terrorist
attack that changed the United States forever. In
its pilot episode, which aired on March 4, 2001,
a hacker — hired by powerful government officials
— takes control of a Boeing aircraft intending to
fly it into one of the World Trade Center towers.
Though the Lone Gunmen manage to stop the plane,
and the terrorist involved is a hacker instead
of hijackers, the show's events are uncannily
similar. In fact, conspiracy theories continue
to circle that the real attack was
orchestrated by the U.S. government,
just like on the show. Despite this unintentional
prediction, right down to the brand of the plane,
not many people made the connection between the
episode and the September 11, 2001, attacks.
"The Lone Gunmen" executive producer
Frank Spotnitz told The Daily Star,
"I woke up on September 11 and saw it on TV
and the first thing I thought of was 'The Lone
Gunmen.' But then in the weeks and months that
followed, almost no one noticed the connection."
Despite running for only 21
episodes between 1987 and 1988,
"Second Chance" – later titled "Boys
Will Be Boys" — makes an eerily spot-on
prediction about the eventual death of the
Libyan dictator, Colonel Muammar Gaddafi.
Set in the then-futuristic year of 2011, Saint
Peter greets newly deceased souls and has them
take a test to determine if they'll be spending
eternity in heaven or hell. In one episode,
Gaddafi appears before Peter, in disbelief
that he's dead. When asked to step onto a
machine to decide his fate, it
lights up red. Peter tells him,
"Because you have ordered the deaths of
innocent people by means of terrorist
explosives, you are sentenced to
spend eternity wired as a human bomb."
Peter's comment likely refers to the April
5, 1986 bombing of a West Berlin dance hall,
where two were killed and over
200 were injured. As predicted
in "Second Chance," Gaddafi died in
2011. Aided by the U.S., Britain,
and France, he was killed at the hands of his
own people, who had enough of his lengthy regime.
In June 2005, a mere month before four terrorists
bombed the London Underground and a bus,
the cast of "Spooks" — a British drama about
security intelligence agents working to prevent
threats — shot an episode that involved an
attempted bombing on the city's transportation
network. Though the fictional agents stopped the
attack, this wasn't the case in the real-life July
7 event, which killed 52 and injured over 770.
"Spooks" star Peter Firth told The Independent,
"At one point, the episode wasn't going
to be shown because it was too near
the mark. In the end, the episode went
out in a very heavily edited version."
The amended episode eventually aired in September
2005, just a few months after the real bombing.
The show's ability to predict the
future wasn't limited to this instance,
with another example including Russian tensions
with the U.K. Richard Armitage, who played agent
Lucas North, was a little freaked out over
the show's preemptive plotlines, commenting,
"Are the 'Spooks' team writing
the newspapers as well?"
"Legends of Chamberlain Heights" was
a Comedy Central cartoon that followed
three aspiring young basketball players,
running from 2016 to 2017. In one episode,
the trio of Grover, Malik, and Jamal
encounter the legendary Kobe Bryant
after a helicopter crash. He's on the ground
being crushed by the chopper while clutching
his trophies and asking the boys to help him.
Before they can act, the helicopter explodes.
In January 2020, Bryant died tragically in a
helicopter crash along with his 13-year-old
daughter Gianna. Overcome by thick fog, the
pilot was said to have lost his sense of spatial
awareness. This caused him to unintentionally
fly downward and crash into a hillside, where
the helicopter exploded into flames. None of the
nine individuals on board survived the incident.
Captain James T. Kirk and Science Officer Mr.
Spock are rather stressed in "Star Trek" Season 2,
Episode 26, "Assignment: Earth,"
because interstellar agent Gary
Seven threatens to wreak havoc on
the events of the 20th century. A
particularly eerie moment comes when
Spock talks about an assassination.
"Current Earth crises would fill a tape bank,
Captain. There will be an
important assassination today."
This episode aired on March 29, 1968,
and only a few days later, on April 4,
civil rights activist Martin Luther King Jr. was
shot and killed on his balcony at the
Lorraine Motel in Memphis, Tennessee.
King was actually a massive fan of "Star
Trek," and he was the one who encouraged
actress Nichelle Nichols — one of
the first black women to play such
a powerful character on screen — to stay on
the show as Lt. Uhura after she contemplated
leaving TV for Broadway. Nichols said in
a Reddit AMA thread that King told her,
"If you leave, they can replace you with a
blonde-haired white girl, and it will be like
you were never there. What you've accomplished,
for all of us, will only be real if you stay."
On November 7, 2001, less than two months after
the attack on the Twin Towers in New York,
"South Park" creators Trey Parker
and Matt Stone did what they do best:
concoct an over-the-top episode about a headline.
In Season 5, Episode 9, the boys travel to
Afghanistan to return a goat sent to them by
four Afghan children as reciprocation for the $1
their teacher forced them to donate. While there,
Cartman and friends are taken hostage by bin Laden
and the Taliban. After a "Looney Tunes"-esque
segment between Cartman and the militant,
bin Laden finds himself donning an Uncle
Sam ensemble. Not knowing who he is, bin Laden's
followers fire at him, causing the explosive in
his hand to detonate. A U.S. Navy SEAL then
delivers one more shot to bin Laden's head.
To put it lightly, this is not how
things went down in real life. Still,
Parker and Stone got a few things right. He
was secretly living in plain view of everyone,
though in Pakistan, not Afghanistan. And,
of course, he was shot and killed by a SEAL.
In Season 10, Episode 22 of "Family
Guy," several tales are told,
including one where Peter Griffin gains
the ability to turn everyone in Quahog into
Robin Williams. Though it's fun at first,
Peter soon becomes agitated about being
surrounded by endless versions of the actor.
He even tries to kill himself to escape them.
The episode originally aired in May 2012, but
reruns were shown for years after. On August 12,
2014, the episode finished airing on
BBC Three in the U.K. just as the news
broke of Williams' death by suicide. A
BBC spokesperson told The Independent,
"This was a repeat that we have shown a
couple of times before, so who could have
planned that? It was scheduled more than two
weeks ago, it is just an uncanny coincidence."
Another "Family Guy" episode came extremely close
to predicting the death of U.S. Supreme Court
Justice Antonin Scalia. In Season 5, Episode
18, Peter calls on Death to send him back in
time so that he can stop his 18-year-old self from
canceling a date with his now-wife Lois. However,
Peter accidentally changes the past,
and Lois ends up with Glenn Quagmire.
When Peter asks Death to send him back so
he can make things right, Death recounts,
"Dick Cheney, the chairman of Haliburton,
shot Supreme Court Justice Scalia in a hunting
accident and the bullet went right through
him and killed Karl Rove and Tucker Carlson."
While that exact outlandish
situation did not happen,
Scalia did die while on a hunting
getaway in Texas. On February 13,
2016, about a decade after the 2007 "Family
Guy" episode aired, Scalia was found dead
by ranch owner John Poindexter after the
Associate Justice didn't attend breakfast.